Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. And I cannot wait
for this show because I got my friend
Dave Weiss in here. If you have not
heard of Dave Weiss, he's also known as
Flatear Dave and he has a website,
flateardave.com.
And what's on here? What What you got
going on, man? How you doing tonight?
>> Hey, I'm doing good. Thanks for having
me.
>> Yeah, dude. I I actually got to see you
live twice and your presentation just
killed it and I was like, man, I got to
have you share this with our audience.
But, uh, on your website, Flat Earth
Dave, what actually brought me here was
the app. I got this app. This thing is
awesome. You want to talk about it real
quick? What it does?
>> The app is I I developed it originally
for myself. I just when I was be talking
to people on the street, I'd be looking
for videos and it just didn't work and
images that I'd put in my photos and
they they'd be like buried. And then I
thought about making this app. I made
the app. I wasn't even going to publish
it. And then uh everyone that saw it
like how where do I get it? So I I
listed it for free. People kept saying,
"Hey, can you add this? Can you add
that?" So I started adding things. I was
like, "You know what? This is starting
to cost a lot of money." So I charged $3
for the app to fund it. Adding more and
more and more stuff. um you know all the
way up to the friendfinder and the
dating you know the the matchmaker and
the meetup maker and uh I had to charge
a subscription for that which is $11 a
year literally is less than a beer at a
bar.
>> Oh, that's awesome. And uh yeah and so I
I made it to help people educate
themselves and educate others because as
you know I think this is the underlying
foundation of all the lies the globe and
it's how the world is in such a crappy
place um depending on how you look at it
of course
>> and um you know waking people up to this
foundation of truth um is the key to
freeing us from the matrix.
Yeah, that's a that's a really bold
statement for people that have never
looked into this. They're like, "Why
does this even matter?" If you guys want
to check out Dave's channel, it's
actually Di TR H, which stands for Deep
in the Rabbit Hole. It's not Darth, it's
Deep in the Rabbit Hole. But, uh, check
out his channel, man. He's got so many
videos on here. He goes live.
>> I look at that that it's a great channel
because it's got all short videos on it.
Then I have multiple channels. I have my
flat earth Dave interviews channel.
There's two of those actually.
>> Nice.
>> Um and those are all linked in the app,
linked on my website. And uh you know, I
just tell people do do the research.
There you go. There's Owen. [snorts]
>> Yeah. So you said a bold statement here.
You said understanding this topic is
like breaking out of the matrix. Like
this is Pandora's box. You need to
understand this. Why? Because when I
promoted this just hours ago, there were
a lot of people that are on board.
There's people that are saying, um, why
does this even matter? Why you wasting
your time? It's not a salvation issue.
What What is your answer to that? I know
mine, but what is what do you say?
>> No, it is a it is a salvation issue. For
one, you know, my personal story is I
didn't believe in God until I discovered
the earth is flat and I realized there
has to be a God. There is no choice. So,
um you know, so that's that's one of the
reasons that they hide it because they
don't want a public um society that
can't deny creation. They always want to
keep doubt in your head um about
creation.
>> So, you know, what difference does it
make? I still have to go to work on
Monday. I still have to go to school on
Monday. You know, what difference does
it make? I still have to pay my electric
bill. And and uh you know, um that's
where they got you. Because once you
understand what this place is, you'll
understand that you shouldn't have to
pay your electric bill. Electricity
should be free. You know, there's
abundance everywhere. We're not overpop
populated. All of the stuff that they
keep you in fear is all nonsense. And um
you know once you understand what a true
powerful creator you are at the center
of creation they can no longer control
you. This is the most important topic of
all time. I gave up everything I worked
my entire life for and succeeded in. I
gave it all up to spread this message.
>> So you're saying when you before you
found God, you believe that you were
just some evolved amoeba that happened
from a big explosion of nothingness.
Everything's an accident. It's all
chaos. You You can You got one life to
live, live it up, which means just
fulfill the lustful desires of your
flesh. Kill or be killed, whatever. But
finding out that we live in a terrarium
with a firmament overhead that's
separating the waters below from the
waters above. There's no endless vacuum.
That the sun, moon, and stars are placed
in the firmament, which if somebody
says, "Well, the firmament is just the
ozone layer, the atmosphere, or the
clouds." you have a huge problem with
the Bible saying the sun, moon, and
stars are in the clouds, right? So, it's
got to be even biblically, even outside
of science and all the cool stuff that
you can show biblically alone with
Genesis, you got some huge problematic
questions like, is the Bible wrong?
>> Early in my life, when I was a young
teenager, there was a uh trip, a group
called Young Life, which was a young
Christian organization, um that was
going on a trip to Bermuda. Sounded like
a lot of fun. and I wanted to go and I
wasn't a Christian. I was born Jewish,
non-practising family and my mom's like,
"You can go." And so I signed up. I went
to Bermuda and the first day they hike
us out to this cliff. They sit us all
down and the counselor is like, "All
right, I'm going to do a little we're
going to do a little Bible verse here,
Bible reading." I'm like, "Oh, that's
that's interesting. Never never heard a
page out of the Bible." And the first
thing he reads was um I forget that the
chapter, but it was about the stars
falling to the earth.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Did Joshua? I'm not even sure. and um
>> revelation talks about
>> the star maybe it was revelation and so
the star and so me being the
helioentrist I'm like a star falling to
the earth that's like that's like you
know a building falling on a grain of
sand you know like it's like it doesn't
make any sense and
>> for the next 40 plus years I refuse to
even consider the Bible as a possibility
of having a single ounce of truth in it
because of that fantasy that is by
design the way so the helioentric model
makes you um reject God essentially.
>> Yeah.
>> But when you know the the now that I
look at it, I mean the more and more and
and by the way I never lead with the
Bible because I remember who I was.
>> Right.
>> Right. If if no matter who I'm listening
to it was great show, great show. Oh,
let's pray. Oh, religious fanatic,
goodbye, unsubscribe, never listening to
again.
>> Yeah. Um, but here I am, you know,
talking, you know, I I believe I even
quoted some Bible verses in my
presentation at the at the at the last
conference I was at at the International
Truth Expo.
>> Yeah, man. So, me and Dave were at uh
International Truth Expo and Truther
Con, and I'm I'm looking forward to
seeing you around at these conventions.
I hope there's more of them. Or or what
I was uh saying is when people look at
this topic and they're like, "This is a
distraction. It's not a salvation
issue." do all this stuff. They don't
say the same thing when it comes to
evolution. I've been in the Christian
world a long time. I was raised
Christian. I I definitely went way far
away, but I came back. I love
apologetics and I used to really be into
like uh answers in Genesis and all those
guys except that they cling to this
heliocentric globe model. But they had a
lot of good points when it came to
debunking evolution. Uh Ken Hovind and
all these guys too. And why would we
spend so much time debunking evolution?
We could say, well, you know, God could
have used evolution. It's not a big,
it's not a salvation issue. Let's stop
paying attention to uh debunking
evolution and let's just talk about
Jesus. That's the way they act when it
comes to the globe. But with when you
understand where we live, it gets rid of
all of it. You can't believe in big bang
evolution. You can't believe um well,
yeah, you can't believe in big bang. You
can't believe in evolution. And you
can't ultimately believe in the soon to
come alien deception. And that's like
for me that's huge because I fell for
the alien deception my entire life.
Second grade I was checking out books on
ghosts and aliens. I wasn't getting good
answers from the church. The church
still doesn't want to talk about the
topic because it sounds too conspiracy
theory or whatever. But we are being
told right now that three Atlas is some
hostile alien on its way to Earth. And
and we're watching this thing through a
through a telescope. We're being told
this and I think it's right around the
corner that there will be full
disclosure. There's already been soft
disclosure for five years. They've been
telling us, "Yep, we see stuff. Yep. We
communicate with non-human
intelligences." Yeah. Uh, whistleblowers
and leaks and all.
>> They're not from outer space. They're
not from outer space. They're from the
outer space. If they're from anywhere,
you know, that's not right here.
>> Exactly. They're interdimensional
deceivers. the when they say it doesn't
matter, you know, if you are a believer
in God, you know, in in the Bible, so
God's creation doesn't matter. The ball
is clearly a satanic model with all the
666es.
>> Um, it's incredible how how satanic it
is. It hides God. It literally keeps us
slaves. How how is that not a salvation
issue,
>> right? Yeah. It it's not a salvation
issue as in there will be people in
heaven that believed the globe. There
will be people in heaven that believe a
lot of things that they didn't have the
truth on. But you are setting yourself
up. If you if you believe this, then
when we come face to face with a
supernatural entity that we've never
seen before and they're saying they're
from another planet and they're here to
they're actually our creators and they
can do lying signs and wonders like the
Bible said and miracle working demons
and they can get rid of climate change
and COVID and all these things, you're
going to you're going to start
questioning a lot of things. You're
going to request everything. But if you
understand that I have to deny my
senses, I have to deny what seems real
to me, my emotions, because truth is
truth. It doesn't care about feelings,
emotions, or any of that stuff. The
truth is there's a glass firmament dome
over us and nothing but water up there.
There are no such thing as aliens
coming. So, let's talk about the
firmament for a second. There's a lot of
different opinions on what's up there.
And here's one thing that I like to say
is anything in the sky, no matter who's
talking about it, a flat-earther, a
helioentrist, an astrophysicist,
a NASA scientist, which is funny. Um,
it's it's just a theory. We do not know.
Now, the only reason that you are saying
that it's crystal is because that's in
the Bible, right? Does it say that it's
an actual crystal or is it
crystalallike? What is it? What is it
actually saying? Um, the only thing I
know in the Bible is it talks about it
being like a looking glass.
>> Yeah. I mean, there's there's all
different ways to interpret it. Now,
personally, I think there is something
solid physical up there, but I I'm not
going to hang my hat on it right there.
You know, you can have, you know, I
think most of us agree there's waters
above and waters below. You can have
waters above with just pressure.
Pressure and and and electrostatic
forces could hold the water up. So it
could be anything from a pressure
firmament. It could be a energetic
firmament. It could be crystal. [snorts]
I don't know. I I think it's crystal. I
don't think it's this big dome like like
we show in in the models. I think it's
more of a flat ceiling, right? It's
pretty it's pretty I mean, if you think
about it, you know, the highest we can
get up is like 72 miles. You that's
where the goast rocket crashed. you know
NASA whistleblower said at 72 miles it
starts turning into plasma then it
becomes liquid and then it becomes
solid.
>> Um but this is you know this is a
whistleblower from NASA.
>> Um
>> but if you look at that you think about
it that's not very high over the map.
That would be that would be if you lay
out the AE map let's say we're using
that map it would be kind of like just
something just like a quarter of an inch
over it all the way across and maybe it
gets lower towards the edges. Again, we
don't want to lock ourselves into a sky
model
>> because, you know, that could take us in
all different ways.
>> Okay. I the things that I've seen in the
Bible, it says it's like molten looking
glass. It's uh
>> I'm with you.
>> Dome vault and things like that. But I'm
I'm glad you're keeping it open for
[clears throat] interpretation because
really the whole the whole thing you're
proving with science even not just the
Bible but science and testable
experiments is it's there's no curvature
and there's no rotation.
>> I think it's a solid thing and in my
opinion if I had to bet on it I'd
definitely I'd go to Vegas and bet on it
for sure. Um but who knows? Um,
>> you got something behind you kind of I'm
gonna full screen you so you can see.
Yeah.
>> What what's going on here? 666.
>> Yeah. This is just all the different
measurements of the helonsical satanic
model. They're all 666s,
>> you know.
>> Wow, dude.
>> There's there's so there's so many. This
is just some of them. So again, is that
you know why why is it like that? Is
that just a coincidence? Yeah, because
these these elitists, whether they're
musicians, just big corporate owners,
whatever it is, they always have to give
their allegiance in some way or another.
Every corporate logo is an eyeball, a a
pyramid, a star, you know, something
that that pledges allegiance to who they
worship. Oh yeah, there you go. Star
Force and Space Force literally is
Baffomet,
>> you know. And these are just these are
just coincidences, right?
>> Yeah. I mean, yeah,
>> coincidence like this happen all the
time. They're always satanic
coincidences
>> on the on the ISS. They were they were
they you know you got the bolt you got
the um the Baffid horns, but I think
this is the one where they do a flip.
Let me just fast forward. Here goes.
He's showing the the There's the 666.
>> What?
Wow, dude. That is crazy.
>> Yeah.
>> Coincidence though, right? It's just a
coincidence.
>> Always a satanic coincidence. Never one
that's like, you know, pointing out
follow Jesus or something. No.
>> So, I I want you to give your best
scientific proof for no curve, no
rotation. I'm looking in here to see it.
Does anybody anybody in the chat have a
globe proof? And actually,
>> well, instead of instead of just saying,
you know, the Earth is a globe, give us
a proof. Instead of saying flat Earth is
stupid because, give us, we don't care
what you think about flat Earth. give us
a globe proof.
>> So, just blast us with some facts that
you got because when you when you gave
that presentation, I was just like,
whoa, how can anybody deny this stuff
when you see it?
>> Yeah, there's there's there's too much.
This is a this is a great experiment
that anyone could do in the winter. Find
a nice big lake. Um, so here's a a lake
uh was frozen, so water large bodies of
water at rest lie flat. When it gets
cold, they freeze flat. We got our
camera 6 in off the ice. We got these
lights out here at uh 8 miles, 7 miles,
6 miles, and 5 miles. Now, to a
heliocentric person that just believes
the Earth is a globe, doesn't know their
own model, they go, "That's not far
enough." But according to your model,
with a crazy amount of refraction that
globers don't even claim, which I added
in here,
>> 30 feet, 22 feet, 15 feet, and 9 ft,
they should be hidden
>> behind the Earth curve. If you and I
were outside and I duck behind a hill,
could you see me?
>> No.
>> Okay.
So, why
do all of these show up on this line?
Now, there's two answers. There's two
answers. One, on a flat Earth, the
camera's on the ice and it's just
looking at these lights across the flat
ice.
>> That's one answer. The other answer is
the camera's on the ice. less than a
mile away is the tangent of the curve of
the earth because the curve of the earth
is less than a mile away at six inches.
And then these are refracting up from
behind this hill and stopping at eye
level. Not going above, not going below.
>> Stopping at perfectly at eye level.
>> Um so so the camera can see it.
>> Oh yeah. Another perfect coincidence.
When people say refraction, you know,
Glob, well, refraction and seven over 6R
and they just start whipping out
equations, I'll give it to them. You can
have refraction. You can say things
refract up. You can say things refract
down. You can say things refract
sideways. You can say things compress,
it doesn't matter. But if something is
behind a physical object, like if I took
this ball and I brought it farther and
farther and farther away, we could say
maybe it would refract up or down. But
if I put it behind something physical,
no matter how far away or what weather
system came in, it's not going to
refract up because there's no light from
this thing getting through the hill, my
hand, whatever.
>> Right? If something is behind a physical
object, there is no refraction. So when
the globers start quoting refraction
this and you know the humidity that ask
them if we're on the Bolivian salt flats
whatever and we built a 10-ft wall brick
wall in between us how far back would we
have to walk before one of us popped
over what weather system would come in
before one of us popped over that wall.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. I mean that that that's what you
you have no one's ever seen it because
it never happens. There is no
refraction. Do you have a um a high
altitude balloon footage to show the
curve? It took me a little bit to
understand what it meant when people
said that the the horizon always is flat
and rises to eye level. I was like, what
does that mean rise to eye level? And
then it it finally made sense to me
because if you are on a ball and you're
flying up, eventually you have to start
looking down at that horizon because
it's curving downward and away from you.
But right here we see that this is a
flat level horizon that has actually
risen to the camera lens which means
that the horizon is actually continuing
to extend outward. But people will say
>> me.
>> Yeah. Good. Go ahead. Finish.
>> Well, I was going to say people will say
that you can sit on the shore and watch
ships sail right over the curve. How
come we can't see a curve side to side?
Neil deGross Tyson will say we're not
high enough that the Red Bull jump he
was not high enough to see curvature. So
how can we watch a ship sail over the
curve? That would mean that that
Earth is shaped like this? Because in
order to watch a ship go over the curve
but not be able to see the horizon side
to side doesn't make sense. If it's a
ball, it has to be curved this way and
curved on the sides. So, I guess that's
when you watch the show,
>> you're
>> you're right and you're wrong. I'm I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna correct you on
this one. Cylindrical.
>> Yeah. A lot of a lot of flat earthers
and glothers, well, all the globers,
they all get this one wrong. So, when
when we're looking out, we can see a
ship disappear and we could see a wide
span. You know, we can see 70 100 miles
or whatever side to side and you think,
all right, where's that curvature?
But in reality, if we lived on a ball,
let's pretend we live on a ball.
>> Mhm.
>> When I look straight forward, there's
going to be a tangent where my eyes hit
the horizon. And that's actually just at
3 miles away. Did you know that on the
ball 24,91 miles around the the Earth
curve 6 feet in just three miles? So at
three miles away, that would be my
physical Earth horizon. You with me?
>> Right. Yep. So on a ball when I'm
looking straight forward, we'll call
that 12:00,
I cannot see the surface of the water
beyond three miles. Agreed?
>> Yep.
>> That's the curvature. Well, we could see
farther than that. So that's problem
number one. Um but the problem is when I
look at 1:00, how far can I see? Where
is that horizon at 1:00? How many miles
out?
>> Still going to be three miles.
>> If it's three miles, how about at two
o'clock?
>> Yep. Same thing. No, I get what you're
saying, but we're we're looking at the
curve from a high altitude balloon,
>> but a high altitude balloon, then maybe
you can see left, right curve.
>> Exactly. If I can
>> on the ground on the ground, you're
going to see flat curvature because the
horizon's going to be at the same eye
level all the way around you. So, there
will not be left to right curve um no
matter how far you can see
>> when you're on when you're on the
ground.
>> Yeah, it'd be like standing on a penny
or something. I agree with that. What
I'm saying is if I can sit on the shore
and watch a ship sail right over the
curve, then I should be able to lift
this balloon right here and definitely
see curvature on side to side because I
just watch ships sail right over from
the from the ground level.
See what I'm saying? Like
>> Yeah, man. So, that that's like that was
a huge
>> win for me for the flat earth. When I
started looking at this, I had to look
at the science because I was like, you
know, scripture can be interpreted this
way and that way. And I I'd seen people
use scriptures that do not prove it.
Like, oh, uh, Nebuchadnezzar had a
vision of a tree that rose and everybody
could see it. I'm like, it's a vision,
you know? So, I looked at all the
science and for like eight months I was
like, okay, both models could work. It
just depends on how you do the math. An
eclipse could happen because the sun is
really far away and it's super big and
the moon is closer and it's smaller and
it just happens to be the same size or
they are local and relatively the same
size and that's why. So I was like both
models could work. But after like eight
months of just really looking at both
sides, the only model that continued to
crumble and still crumbles to this day,
that was 2016, is the heliocentric globe
model every time.
>> Yeah. This is at 100,000 ft um by an
amateur. 100,000 ft amateur. 100,000 ft
amateur NASA. [laughter]
>> Great.
>> Okay.
>> Amazing.
>> We got another question that said, uh my
question though is why hide this? The
reason is because Satan is trying to
deceive the world. He doesn't want you
to know that you that there's a creator
that created you and this terrarium with
luminaries that are like clockwork
overhead. If you found that edge of the
dome, I think it was uh Mark Sergeant on
his flat earth clues, he said when you
have anything inside of a box, like a
hamster or something, they're always
trying to get out. They're like digging
on the side of the walls or whatever,
but when you have cows that are in this
acres and acres of footage, they don't
even pay attention to the fence. They
don't realize they're in inside anything
because they haven't found the wall. So
they are trying to Satan, the elitist
and all them are trying to keep us from
finding that wall because the next thing
we'll ask is who put this wall here? Why
am I in this container? H who put me
here? But when you're told that we are a
piece of shrapnel flying around in an
everexpanding vacuum of space, you're an
accident. But that's not what we see
when you look at star rotations. We
don't see uh you know cork screwing
spinning around all directions in an
everexpanding universe. You see Polaris
staying in the same place year round.
>> If we saw if we no matter how big the
courtyard is, if we see the fence, we're
going to want to know what's on the
other side of the fence. So, they took
our map, they cut it out, they wrapped
it around a sphere, and they told us,
"We can't disturb the penguins in the
white area, right?" You know, you can
spend a lot of money, go to this little
peninsula right here, and uh that's it.
You can't go out here, though. And you
can't fly over there either because it's
too cold, right? You have to go all the
way to the north and all the way back
down to go from one southern continent
to the other. No, no, no shortcuts
across the bottom. The there's there's a
few different types of people. There's
people that know the earth is flat.
There's anti-flate earthers that are
just here to fight flat earth. They
don't care um whatever their motivation
is, paid or possessed, it doesn't
matter. It's the same thing. Um, and
then there's ignorant people that just
can't break their indoctrination because
their brains were too soft until they
were seven when they were just
completely programmed and they're
unwilling to do the work to unprogram.
Like when you have a bad habit, you have
to do some work to get rid of that
habit. You have to break the
programming. And the programming for the
globe is stronger than
>> anything you've experienced in your
life.
What is what is your favorite best
evidence that we don't live on the
globe?
>> The one for me is, you know, we can see
too far. You just, you know, boats over
the horizon. Um that's that's the best
one, you know, and then just logically
thinking about um air pressure, air
pressure, you know, um high pressure
next to low no pressure without a
container. It makes absolutely
uh absolutely no sense. And then, you
know, I've been doing a lot of filming
of boats going into the distance and
they just do all sorts of weird miragey
things. They just disappear. One of my
favorites is uh I would say the sun fade
out videos. And you know, when the
Globber saw that the first they accuse
me of Photoshop, you know, then they're
like, you know, I've watched millions of
sunsets and you know, I've never seen
that. Well, you're not going to see it
unless you film it on a super clear day
from altitude, cold. Um, and you know,
the sun went down, down, down, down,
down. It was going down, down, down,
down, down. And then it kind of just
stopped and sat there. And so my friends
were down here at the beach. They saw
the sunset 10 minutes ago from the
bottom up. And I'm still watching it.
It's just sitting here.
>> This is This is sped up. It's just
sitting here and it's going farther and
farther away. And we're we're
brainwashed into believing that light
travels forever, but it doesn't. It it
insuates into the atmosphere. It just
absorbs. It's like somebody walking into
a fog bank, right? Over distance, the
sunlight can no longer make it to us.
I'm going back and forth here. It's just
going away. Sun's right there. You just
can't see it
>> coming back and going back and forth.
Um, and I'm not the only one that's
filmed this. Numerous people have filmed
this. I even live streamed two of them
um to show that it wasn't photoshopped
or anything.
>> Yeah. So, sunsets, that's a great segue.
What? How do you explain sunsets or the
the sun looking like it's under the
clouds or any of that kind of stuff?
Because it just doesn't make sense.
>> So, well, the horizon, you know, we
everyone likes to say the horizon rises
to eye level. I I want to correct that.
The [snorts] horizon always appears to
rise to eye level. In actuality, over
distance, the horizon is still 6 feet
under, you know, if you're 6 feet tall,
six, it's six feet below your eyes. But
in reality, the horizon, what is the
horizon? The horizon is the point, that
line that you can't see back any
farther. And there's different horizons.
There's the Earth horizon, and then
there's the sky horizon. The sky horizon
is all of the atmosphere, right? So,
when you look out and there's a a cloudy
day. Um there there's um you know,
cumulus clouds. Is this is this one? Um
>> that's not the one. I'm trying to show
you another one.
Um,
well, I'll show you this one. So, this
is a cloud and imagine there's a whole
bunch of clouds and as they go into the
distance, they look like they're getting
lower, right? But they're just going
farther away. So, these clouds, let's
say they're at, I don't know, 10,000 ft.
Um, at 25 miles away, they look like
they're touching the horizon. So, all
these clouds are the same height, just
like the street lights, right? So, this
cloud is the same height as this cloud,
>> right? You know that logic doesn't look
like it. Now, if we drew a string from
this guy's eyes to that cloud, it would
look like it's paralleling the water.
It's like it's going right over the
Earth, right? It looks parallel.
>> Now, if we push that cloud a little
farther, it's going to merge into that
horizon line, and he's not even going to
be able to tell the difference between
the ground and it.
>> Yeah.
>> So, a celestial object like the sun
above it is just going to go beyond it.
So if somebody was standing under that
cloud, he would see the line sloping
down to his eyes. But this guy sees the
line going straight across the water.
Right? This is the guy in the distance
under that that far cloud and he can see
the line this the string going straight
down. Right? So this guy's point of
view, he sees the the line going
straight across. This is the cloud
that's far in the distance on the
horizon. So as the sun just goes beyond
it, it gets blocked by this cloud
horizon. And if there's not clouds over
distance, the air becomes like a cloud.
It becomes opaque. And then the sun will
just get blocked behind it. But this is
not how he sees. Remember, this is the
guy that's underneath that cloud. This
is what he would see, right? He wouldn't
see the sun disappearing behind it. But
from his perspective, what we just saw
there actually looks like this. He's
looking across. This cloud is literally
merged with the horizon. He can't really
see the difference. As the sun goes
away, it looks like it's getting lower
and lower and it just goes beyond
this celestial atmospheric deck horizon.
This this uh I call it the atmospheric
deck of opacity. And it's just going
beyond it. And then people just, oh no,
that's the Earth. That's the Earth.
That's the Earth. So this horizon,
where's the horizon? So this is my my
kitchen sunset. This line is level,
[laughter] right? It's this line right
here. But look what's this going behind.
It's not the ground. It's not the land.
It's just going beyond this atmospheric
deck.
>> Wow.
>> And if I zoomed out, that line literally
would just become one line. If I zoomed
out, you wouldn't be able to tell the
difference.
>> So, this uh this experiment is your
experiment. You're moving a fake sun
across a flat surface and it looks like
it's setting.
>> Yeah. Here, I'll show you. Here's I call
it my kitchen sunset. So, I'm I'm
showing here that this line is level
across the counter. Um, these bottles
and cardboard, we'll consider that a
mountain, if you will, or clouds,
whatever. I'm just showing that this sun
is never going below it, cuz I'm filming
it from an elevated position. I'm
filming it from a celestial position.
Now, I have a terrestrial camera on the
counter on the other end that I just
filmed that same thing. And from a
terrestrial point of view, this level
line looks like it's sl it's tilted
down. And the sun looks like it goes
below those bottle mountains.
>> That's awesome,
>> right? It looks like it goes below it.
And if I zoom in even more, and I showed
you this first, I would say, "Is this
line level?" And you're like, "No way.
It's almost going straight down." This
is a level line. And this is just going
beyond it. Push that into the distance.
That's going to look like your horizon.
That's your horizon. That's at that'll
appear to be at your eye level, but it's
thousands of feet above your eye level.
And that's what we see right there.
>> Wow. Hey, we got a phone call. I uh put
the number in there. So, let's let's
hear what's up. Hey, man. You're on
Candid Truth. You got a question?
>> Oh, Mike, I just wanted to say, tell
them about the Antarctic Treaty that all
these goofy countries are doing. There's
got to be a reason why they don't want
you there. Okay, I'll free up the line.
I love you. Bye-bye.
>> Cool. Love you, Dad. Bye. That was
actually my dad who became a
flatearther. So, yeah. What's up with
this Antarctic treaty? they were doing
project high jump uh in you know in
Antarctica and right after that they
came up with the Antarctic treaty where
all these countries all the major
countries in the world basically all the
countries have signed on it that nobody
can independently explore Antarctica and
then they're like we're going to the
moon don't look over there look over
here you know
>> it's a literally a wizard trick and um
you know there's two things that the
that all these countries can agree upon
they fight they war you know all these
wars nonsense But Antarctica supposedly
filled with resources, you know,
precious metals, gold, um,
um, fuel, all sorts of stuff. Everyone
agrees can't go there. Can't go there.
And everyone and they also agree that
everyone has to become a human pin
cushion because if you breathe on
grandma, it's going to kill her. Right?
So again, if you don't understand, you
know, the deception that's going on
here, and if you look, this is uh,
there's all of these bases. This is the
Faulland Islands right here. remember
the Faulland Islands war? Like, why
aren't we fighting over that little
island? It's cuz they needed to put
bases here so they can literally patrol
all of this area. This is a vast area,
but there are military bases here that
are literally guarding all of this
territory around. So, nobody can go
beyond there and find out what this
place is.
>> Wow. Yeah, dude. That's crazy. Um, we do
have another caller. You're on, Jen. Go
ahead and ask a question.
>> Hi, brother Mikey. What's up, Mr.
>> Jen? How are you
>> doing? Good.
>> Um, I'm I'm calling in because I want to
share something that I have found in the
Bible. I agree that the earth is flat.
>> Okay.
>> Um, so I wanted to just share this like
it shows here on the fourth day and this
is um chapter 1 of verse of Genesis
verse um let's say 15
>> okay
>> or 14. It says, "And God said, let there
be lights in the firmament of the heaven
to divide the day of from the night, and
let them be for signs and for seasons
and for days and years. And let them be
for lights in the firmament in
>> the firmament
inside the firmament.
>> So I don't believe that the sun is is
bigger than the earth."
>> Good point. I think it's within
>> the firmament that was separated in the
very beginning portion.
>> So, can you hear me?
>> I think that Satan would want us to
believe
>> that the sun is bigger than the earth
>> because they would want to worship,
right?
>> Y
>> but it is only it's smaller. So let me
let me throw in my
>> my my two cents here is
>> I think the sun that we see is a
projection like I showed on my
presentation um that we see an apparent
sun inside of the our dome of vision. So
we're in this this space this realm and
I think that the sun itself the actual
source sun is above the rakia above
whatever it is that's enclosing us. How
does that fit biblically? Well, when I
say above, it's above what we're
underneath it, right? Who knows how
thick it is? It could be, you know,
millions of miles thick. Who knows,
right? And and so the the the the thing
that I ask is when you put your milk in
the refrigerator, do you put it in the
refrigerator or you put it under the
refrigerator?
>> In.
>> Okay. So in could be above the firmament
that we see.
So the sun itself I think is above and
it's projecting in. If you take one of
those uh little um if you got one of
those pendants I got hold it out in the
light you know get a glass dome hold in
the light or an upside down bowl and
hold a light above it you'll see a sun
inside floating inside just like we see
it in the sky. So the sun that we see is
just a projection or reflection of the
source sun in my opinion.
>> Yeah. Do you got like a a sample to show
of that?
>> Um that's Well, here's a real world
>> a real world reflection. Um
where is my
Oh, here we go. Nope.
Here. Let me ask you this.
Which one is the sun and which one is my
iPhone light?
>> Oh, good question. I mean, it I would it
looks like the one on the right cuz it's
like blue, but I'm guessing it's the one
on the left
>> because it's a trick question.
>> I'm trying to trick you.
>> Yeah, I'll go with the left.
>> It It's the My iPhone is the one with
the blue,
>> but I I I had to check which one it was.
>> Yeah. I mean, I I really don't know. I
was just trying to not be tricked.
>> Yeah, I wasn't trying to trick you. I I
tricked myself to be honest. Um,
I got a glass dome on the rug here on a
white rug and I'm bringing a pen light
in across.
>> So, here's the source sun.
>> Here it comes. And here's the sun we see
inside.
>> Wow.
>> And as it goes away, just like the sun
fade out, it never goes below. It just
stops and fades out.
>> Wow, dude. That's
>> and here [clears throat] it comes back
again. So it'll it'll appear.
>> Imagine you were inside. You see the sun
appear on the horizon. It moves
overhead,
>> right? The source sun is up here going
away. It goes down, down, down, down,
down, and it stops and it fades out.
>> Wow.
>> Just like we see in reality.
>> That's amazing.
>> All right, let's see what this caller
has to say. All right, you're you're on
the air to ask Dave a question.
Um so in the flat earth model that I
usually see right the sun seems to um go
around the edge of the earth right
and this is where the
uh swall
is according to this model. Wouldn't
wouldn't the edges be the hottest part?
>> If
>> All right, let me ask you that.
>> That's a good question. So,
>> yeah,
>> basically,
for anybody that might not have heard,
basically a question is like, how do we
get seasons? How do we get different
temperatures if the sun is just always
like
floating above the outer ring?
>> Yeah, that's not what it that's not what
it does, though. They they're not
understanding what they're what they're
seeing. So, here is the sun. It's going,
this is almost as far out as it going to
go. It's going to go out until December
21st. It'll go out to this yellow uh
ring, which is the Tropic of Capricorn.
And it's only out here for a little bit
of time. And then it starts going back
in. Takes 6 months to get all the way
into the inner ring. Let's bring it in.
Um
1 2 3 4 5 6. So, the sun will come in
here in June. May June. Bring it to
June. Um, and that's when we have our
summer in here. So, it's freezing at the
North Pole.
It's summer here cuz it comes right over
Miami. So, we get our northern our
northern summer when the sun is close.
And then remember, it only goes from
here to here, back and forth, back and
forth. So, this is the tropics, which is
in between the tropics. That's where
it's the hottest because the sun is
radiating the earth and every night the
earth is radiating heat and it radiates
the earth and it's radiating heat and at
different times of the year depending on
how far it is. Sometimes it'll radiate
more out [snorts] at night. So it'll get
colder and colder and colder as the sun
moves farther away. So the sun is moving
it's going all the way out to where are
we now? Let me stop it. Um in November
it's way out here. So that's why it's
getting so cold in here.
So out here is Antarctica in all
directions. So the sun's they have a
very short summer and then the sun goes
away. So it didn't give it that much
radiant heat and so that's why it gets
so cold in Antarctica.
That's awesome because um yeah,
>> something you just said made me think it
makes a lot more sense that we are
inside of a dome with a little ball
that's a heater flying over because I've
actually seen experiments and you may
disagree, but I've seen experiments
where they take a uh thermometer, a
laser thermometer, and they under a
moonlight when it's hitting the
pavement, it's actually cooler than in
the shadows. So, there's a a thought or
an idea that the moon is actually
radiating
a cooling light and the sun is radiating
a a a heating light. And so, inside here
in this dome, we're being heated up and
cooled down. Heated up and being cooled
down. Now, that makes a lot more sense
than we're some ball floating in a
vacuum. There's a giant gas ball on fire
and just because it moves
slightly, you know what I'm saying? like
how is the temperature change so
extremely if the sun is only slightly
further from us or something like that.
>> Let's let's um let's let me show you in
the app. If you go to the images and
just type in seasons, I just added this
picture. So, this was last February. Um,
I was here in uh, Mexico in the tip of
the Yucatan Peninsula and it was it was
actually 90 to 95 degrees uh, about 2
o'clock in the afternoon and in
Connecticut
it was -10.
>> That's 100° 100°. Now that's 0.00003%
00003%
farther because the tilt of the earth if
you calculate how much farther
Connecticut is from the sun it's 0.3%
farther.
>> Yeah. How is that?
>> But the global but hold on the globalist
will go it's not the distance it's the
tilt. Well you think about it. The earth
is spinning all day long. So the tilt of
the sun is changing all day long. It's
the qu you know. So only one tilt
matters. But here's the thing. So that's
the difference. 100 degree swing.
Absolutely ridiculous. But if you look
at it on a flat Earth at that time, the
sun was right out here.
That little yellow line is the distance
from the sun to the Yucatan. And the
green line is the distance to
Connecticut from the sun. It's twice the
distance. Wow. Twice the distance.
[laughter]
Which one makes sense?
>> Yeah, dude. Yeah. This is an amazing
app, you guys. If you want to have these
resources, go to flateardave.com
or on the Google Play Store or whatever,
download FEC clock. Is that what it's
called officially?
>> Yeah, it's called the flat earth sun,
moon, and zodiac clock app. Just go to
my website um and get it. And you you
can uh you can take it and you can send
it to somebody, you know, you can text
it to them, whatever. You can you can
send all of all of these uh images. Um
the flash cards, they're they're
amazing. Um but let that one soak in.
This is a globe killer. When someone
asks you about seasons, there's the
explanation. There is no other
explanation. When they when they go
tilt,
>> say, "Well, what about the sun in the
morning? It's tilted all the way down to
the ocean and then it rises up." So the
tilt tilts, it's going from 0 degrees up
to, you know, as high as it goes. if
you're on the equator, 90° or whatever.
Um, but that's tilt also.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's it can be a lot
colder at night than it is in in the at
noon.
>> And it's only because we're tilted
slightly.
>> It the tilt is so stupid. You know, it I
I say in June on the solstice, I can
watch the sunrise and I could feel the
heat on my face. It's instantly warm.
It's 85 degrees, right? And that's at
that's at dawn. That's at the the
beginning of the day in June, right? And
the sun is 89° tilt. It couldn't be any
farther. Then in December 21st, the at
noon when the sun's like 50° up in the
sky, much more direct and 3 million
miles closer, but that doesn't matter.
Um, I can't even feel the heat on my
face.
>> That is amazing.
>> But the globers the globers, you know,
um can't even fathom that. Like there
you got a guy in your chat that's like,
"What about the circle of the earth?"
Well, the circle of the earth. Here's
the circle of the earth right here. It's
circle.
>> Circle.
>> Okay. It's a circle. It's not the sphere
of the earth. Show me the sphere of the
earth. The four corners of the earth.
Well, may maybe the these are the four
corners. One, two, three, four.
>> There's four corners. Show me four
corners on a globe.
I this is this is crazy because we've
always been told that if we're in this
perfect Goldilocks zone and if the sun
were an inch closer we would burn up and
if it was an inch further we'd freeze.
And yet you look at the same people that
are telling you this and it's in January
look how far we are to the sun and then
in July look how far we are to the sun.
These are the same people that are
telling us if there's an inch difference
we would burn up or freeze. And yet, and
this is one that I like, if it's okay,
in January, nighttime stars are to the
right out here, and you look up and you
see stars and then in July, nighttime is
this way, to the left. You're looking
this way at the stars. How can you see
Polaris all year round? Polaris never
moves. It's visible all year round. And
you're on total opposite sides of this
thousand times bigger earth bigger than
Earth's sun. 93 million miles this way.
The dis the diameter of the sun 93
million miles this way. And you're
seeing the same stars looking opposite
directions. It doesn't even make sense.
>> Nighttime is that way
and nighttime is that way.
>> Yep.
>> It m it makes absolutely no sense. And
you can see the same stars. Now, you can
argue Polaris is up this way, but you
know, we're told that the that Polaris
is just special to the Earth because it
matches where our axis is, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Imagine. So, imagine that there's
um that there's other planets, Saturn,
Mars, Mercury, right? That they're not
just lights in the sky, that there other
planets with people on them. Would
somebody on Mars give a rats behind uh
that um about Polaris? Polaris wouldn't
be important to them. Right.
>> Right.
>> It would just be another star in the
sky. Right. So if we're here, not to
scale, here's the Earth. Polaris would
be up there, let's say. Right. Polaris,
this is our axis of spin. Well, if we
were tilted this way, then who would
care about Polaris? It would whatever
stars over here would be our pole star,
right?
>> Everyone can agree, right? So what if
the the these are the axises of all the
other planets, right? They all have
their own pole star. It wouldn't matter.
It would nobody would care about anyone
else's pole star because it would just
be another random star in the sky. But
for that planet, it's pointing to the it
axis is pointing there. We can all agree
globers will agree with all of that. The
problem is we're told that the that the
planets um all circle the sun, but in
reality they all circle Polaris.
Mercury, Venus, Mars, Juno is an
asteroid, right? They all make these
spyroraph patterns circling Polaris.
Wait a minute. 2,000 years ago, I
thought it was Thubin that was our north
star. Did they all circle Thubin and
switch over to Polaris?
>> No way. Okay, it's almost 2026
>> and people [clears throat] still believe
in the spinning wet rock in space.
People will defend it. They don't even
know what they're saying.
>> Yeah,
>> it's it's unreal. It's unreal.
>> Got another caller.
>> Space is unreal. Go ahead.
>> You're on uh You can ask Dave a
question.
>> We got We got about 10 more minutes. I
got to I got to run.
>> Thanks. This is Andrew. I believe in the
uh flat non-rotational Earth
and um there there's a lot of
interesting stuff on this. I appreciate
everything you guys have covered. Um, I
mean, even going back and looking at the
Gleon's map, you got there in the late
1890s
and then early uh 1910s, you got
Universal Studios putting out their logo
of a globe.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> And then the first images of space don't
even show up uh till 1946.
But um the question I had that came to
me the other day that would be
interesting to know, Dave, would be um
how a compass works. I feel like a
compass with the magnetic north should
be able to prove the flat earth. And I
was wondering if you've ever looked into
that and what proofs you have around a
compass and the magnetic poles that can
show that it's flat, non-rotational.
>> Awesome, man. Thank you so much for your
question. That's a good one. I'm going
to let you go so he can answer.
>> Yeah, the comp the compass is a good
one. Um, and I did a little experiment
right here. I got my map out. I got a
neodyium magnet here and I got a compass
and the needle is pointing towards the
center. So west is 90 degrees off of
that. So I'm trying to push the compass
west, but I got to keep turning to the
right to maintain a heading of 270. So
west is a circle
around a magnetic north on a flat plane.
Compasses only work on a flat plane. And
now east is also a circle. I can't go
straight because the compass is my
heading my heading will change. So, I
have to keep turning because I have to
keep following the needle all the way
around. Now, if I wanted to dead wreck,
dead wreck west. So, here I am. I want
to dead wreck. I'm I'm going to say,
"Okay, west is that way." And I'm not
going to correct to the north. Right? As
soon as I start going, watch the compass
needle will turn and I'm heading south.
>> Right? The magnet's actually not strong
enough. It it should turn a little bit
more, but that is south. South is every
direction away from north. South is all
of these lines are going south because
they're the opposite direction of north.
Now on a flat Earth, if you go south,
you'll never come back. On a globe
Earth, if you go south, you'll pop up on
the other side. No one's ever gone from
Santiago and ended up in Australia ever,
right? You just keep on going. So if I
go north, I'm going in a straight line.
I'm going north. And as soon as I pass
the North Pole,
I go south. The compass just did a 180.
Every straight line is south. No matter
which direction you point, you're
pointing south.
Compasses absolutely prove that the
earth is flat because they don't work on
balls.
>> West is this way. These are circles
going clockwise are west.
>> All right?
>> Right? Because they e they go around the
northern center here.
>> Right?
>> On the equator, I would just go
straight. Right. On the equator, I could
just go straight. I wouldn't have to
turn. So,
>> yeah.
>> So,
if I had this airplane flying here, I'd
have to keep turning to the right to
maintain a heading of west.
>> Gotcha. You
>> with me?
>> Yep.
>> Right. And on the down and on the bottom
on the south, I'd have to turn left to
maintain that heading,
>> right?
>> See how I'm turning left?
>> Yeah, definitely. It's like um like the
tracks on a racetrack or something.
>> Yeah. But on a but on a flat earth, it's
different. On a flat earth in the north
and in the south, I always have to turn
right to maintain that heading.
>> Wow. Yeah.
>> So, that is a determination. Now, we
have any evidence which way you turn.
Well, we have Navy ship captains, you
can find it on Mark Sergeant's channel,
that talk about in the South when
they're trying to dead wreck an east or
west, they constantly have to correct to
the north. And when they question their
admirals about it, they're told, "Don't
worry about it."
they constantly have to correct to the
north. So, an experiment that could be
done with a what's called a a um compass
gyro. It's not a magnetic compass. It's
a compass that spins like a gyro
upright. You line it up with east west
and then you follow it because it won't
pay attention to magnetics. And so when
you're going west in the southern
hemisphere, your west will peel off to
the right, proving that the earth is
flat when in reality it should pull off
to the left of the earth as a globe.
There's your experiment right there. In
the south and in the north, planes
always have to turn to the right. You
see?
>> Yeah.
>> They have to turn to the right. On the
globe, I showed you the the south one
has to turn to the left.
They're both turning to the right to
maintain their heading. And that's what
we experience in reality.
>> Wow. So, you're saying that flights
really do have to kind of curve. And
>> well, you wouldn't even notice it. Like
if you were even when you're on in the
air, you'd never notice it. But if you
were on a a racetrack that was 500
miles, that's just 500 miles in a
circle, you'd feel like you're driving
on a straight road,
>> right?
>> It would feel like a straight road.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I'm glad you brought up the
flight stuff because there's there's so
many flight patterns that don't make
sense on a ball that do make sense on
flat Earth. There's, you know, if you're
a plane flying on top of a ball, you
would have to continuously dip your nose
down to keep from just flying straight
out into space.
>> Any direction on a ball, you'd have to
dip your nose down.
>> Yeah. And there, you know, you can fly a
drone for an hour and land it. It
doesn't end up 1,000 miles away because
we're told that the Earth rotates 1,000
miles an hour.
>> Um, one more call then I then I got to
run. I got um
>> got a call coming right now.
>> All right. You're on the air. Ask Dave a
question.
>> Yeah. Um, well, this is uh this is
Tyler. I have a friend who is name is
Axiom. He believes the earth is uh
round.
>> Okay.
>> You know, like uh that it's a sphere.
and he's quoted that
>> the farther you get up or something like
that it there's something about that
where it has to be a uh spear because of
the farther you get up looks more like a
spear or something like that or he said
something along like I don't know you
can ask you know axiom right
>> so so does it look like a spear because
it looks is that why it looks
>> okay well hey Dave's answering your
question
>> yeah Dave's gonna answer your question
right now thanks for the call bro
>> all right He says it looks like a
sphere, but you go up, we just see a
flat. Unless you have a fisheye lens, it
looks like a sphere.
>> But it it looks flat. And then no matter
how high we go, it looks it it
absolutely looks flat.
>> Absolutely.
>> That's it. No matter, you know, what
level you're at, it's it's it's
literally flat. Sea level,
cloud level, mountain level, sky, it's
just flat. Unless of course you're
you're NASA and you're using a fisheye
lens. Um you can see what and you got to
remember we see in a circle like put a
hula hoop around your head at eye level.
That's your horizon. It's curved but
it's flat.
>> Again, you know, for for anyone on the
if you have a did he say he was from a
church
>> the biblical section right here, if you
go um and click this section here where
it says biblical FE, I think the first
video there is called Dear Pastor. It's
an 8-minute video by Matt Long and it is
phenomenal,
>> right? It'll it'll literally introduce
anybody um you know, biblically into how
ridiculous um the globe is and how flat
the Bible is.
>> Yep.
I love it, man. And we're not here to
tell anybody they're stupid. Look, we
all fell for this. All of us. That's
what we do on this channel. Like,
anytime I tell you like every movie is
brainwashing you, it's all subliminal. I
fell for it. I fell for the music. I
fell for the movies. I fell for the
globe. I fell for the occult. I mean, I
was head in. And we've all been
deceived. The Bible says that the dragon
is going to deceive the entire world.
And what is the main way that he can
really deceive the world into not
believing God? Destroy the the
fundamental foundation of Genesis. I
mean, I've heard I've heard people say
this about uh the flood. You have to
believe in a worldwide flood or else you
destroy the foundation of the Bible. If
you can't believe the flood, then you
can't believe the Bible. They say the
same thing about um six days of
creation. If you believe that it's
evolution, millions of years, you
destroy the foundation of the Bible and
therefore you can't believe the Bible.
But when it comes to this topic, we will
totally turn a blind eye to creation
week saying that he put a firmament that
separates the waters below from the
waters above. He put a sun, moon, and
stars in that firmament.
And you know the other places that say
it's a like a dome vault and like strong
like looking glass and all this stuff.
We totally ignore it because we say nope
science has it right on this one. Why
are we going to believe science quote
unquote science the very people who put
in the textbooks that you came from a
monkey and that all of this started from
a magical explosion of nothingness. So
the whole point of this is not to, you
know, focus on some distraction that's
not salvational, but to point you back
to the Bible. God is true. We have a
creator. He put us here and you're not
an accident. And there's no aliens and
there's no evolution. And that's really
what this is all about. The truth will
set you free and to point people away
from the deception that's here and and
soon to come.
>> Awesome. just uh keep seeking truth. Uh
once you see it, help spread it to
others. You know, don't shove it down
their throat. Just offer little
questions, little hints. Um hang out
with other flat- earthers. Come to
Anarch Poco in Mexico. If you're looking
for a place to go this winter, this is
the place.
>> It's a blast. The the people there and
you're on the beach in Mexico. What's
better than that? There you go. 10% off.
Use a use a discount code, just get 10%
off. I think they're having a Black
Friday sale. It might already be in
effect, but after that, the prices go
up. Um, [clears throat] so,
>> wow, man.
>> Check it out.
>> Dave, thank you so much for coming on,
man. It's been a blast hanging out with
you. Thank you for just red pilling us
with all this truth. I know this is the
first time some people have ever heard
this. And so, if they want to know more,
they should check out your app on the
app store. Just look up the flat earth
clock. You should be able to find it
like that. Go to flateardave.com.
Check out his YouTube channel at the
initials for deep inside the rabbit
hole. D I t
or look up flat earth Dave in general.
You'll find them everywhere. You're out
here doing some work, man.
>> All all the links are on my website. The
easiest way to get to the app because
there are some knockoffs on the Google
Play Store. Just go to my website, click
it there. And um you know, also in all
of my videos there's a link there. So
check it out. Check out the crash course
on my website. Check out um check out
whatever you want to check out and just
seek truth, you know. Um verify
everything. Don't believe anything I
say. Don't believe anything what anyone
says in chat. Verify everything. If it
resonates with you, go verify it.
>> Amen.
I love it, bro. Thank you so much, man.
I'm actually going to end this with a
short little video that's showing some
fake space stuff. So, usually I say
stick around. and I'll talk to you after
the show, but I'm going to I'm going to
um I'm going to prove to some people
that fake lift space is fake, too. So,
thank you so much, man.
>> I'll be listening. Thanks.
>> Thanks, bro. I'll catch you later, man.
>> All right. Thanks. See you.
>> I hope this was encouraging to you guys.
If it was, please click a thumbs up. It
really helps get this video out into the
algorithm. A lot of people need to know
this truth because the truth will make
you free. And there's a video on our
channel on Candid Truth. If you guys
have not watched this video, it's called
Serious Questions. It's got uh Buzz
Aldrin throwing up the 666 over his
eyeball, but I want to show since this
was a short show, like it we usually go
a little longer than an hour. This is a
short video, a short produced video
comparing NASA with NASA, comparing the
ISS with the ISS. It's comparing it its
own footage against itself. And there is
zero
uh consistency with these people.
Sometimes their hair is stiff. Sometimes
their hair is floating around.
>> Candy truth.
>> They faked going to the moon. This is
not a conspiracy theory website. The the
footage doesn't have sound, so it's okay
that you guys don't hear it. This is
supposed to be like one of the first
footages of space or of stars in space.
And this thing is floating up.
Everybody's watching. And there's the
glory. Look at the stars. Do you see
that star? Do you know why that is
impossible? Because the moon isn't a
crescent. It's a whole moon that's just
like shadowed. You shouldn't be able to
see a star in the shadow of the moon or
the stars in front of the moon. This is
ridiculous. Like people actually believe
that this is real. But what's awesome is
how many people are waking up. You look
at the comments here and people are
like, "Ah, yes, a star shining through
the moon. Lol." Listen to this. About
stars. When you looked up at the sky,
could you actually see the stars and the
solar corona in spite of the glare?
>> We were never able to see stars from the
lunar surface or on the daylight side of
the moon by eye without looking through
the optics. Uh I don't recall during the
period of time that we were
photographing the Sonar Cora what what
stars we could see.
>> I don't remember seeing any.
>> We just saw stars from a balloon, but
they were in space. They were on the
moon and they're like, "I don't remember
seeing stars ever. I don't remember
seeing any."
>> He's like, "Dude, come on, man. Stop.
It's enough. Do you see that?" He gives
him a look and then he's like
[clears throat] like shrinking back in
his seat.
>> Seeing any
like come on, man. So, you can see stars
from a balloon, but you can't see stars
when you're on the moon. There was a
time when the ISS was doing a supposedly
live feed with a school and somebody
said, "Are you are you able to see stars
in the ISS?" And the guy was like, "Oh,
yeah."
>> You know, and pretty much all the time
you can see the stars.
>> It's It's not a void void. I mean, it's
black, but there's all kinds of little
polka dots.
>> There's all the There's all the stars
there. And the cool thing is about you
can see it during the day.
>> Yeah, you can. And there's more than
stars. You can see planets. You can see
moons. You can see [music] uh the
zodiacal light.
>> Wo!
>> We can see all of the Milky Way all in a
single orbit. If I went to the moon, I
would not look so depressed. People win
the football game and they are so
they're screaming in the locker room.
How NASA makes those incredible high-res
images of Earth. They're saying that
they get the images from a low orbit
satellite that takes ribbons of images
and they have to fill those gaps in. If
they have satellites, why don't they
just go back and take a whole picture of
Earth? Instead, it's literally like an
airplane flying over different parts of
the world, taking ribbons of images that
have to be stitched together on this
globe
>> that can be translated into ribbons of
imagery like [music] this and then into
one of these.
>> They have to put these pieces together,
which means there's empty spaces between
the ribbons that have to be photoshopped
in
>> because there's a very slight gap in
between each orbit.
>> So, some of those are painted on. It is
photoshopped, but it's it's has to be.
All these layers are put together to
make that picture of the blue marble
world that you all see on your iPhones.
He admits it is photoshopped. We had to
fill in the gaps because we don't have
technology to go back far enough and
take a picture of Earth. [music] And yet
people look at this on their phone and
they will show you that and say, "Look,
the Earth is a globe. Here's the proof.
We got a picture of it." This is the
footage that Bart got given of them
faking Halfway to the Moon. Look at the
pattern. That's cloud coverage. There's
no way in all the Earth's history that
that cloud formation could be the same.
If the Earth is turning, clouds are a
vapor that are just being formed all the
time. But yet, when you zoom in on this
picture of an astronaut on the moon and
look at the image of Earth, it's the
same. You see that, right? You see this?
It's the same cloud formation.
Everything about this is the same, which
is why when you put it inside of
Photoshop and start tweaking with the
adjustment layers, you actually see that
it's a square. If you take these
original images and you put them in
Photoshop, we now have the technology,
the people have the technology to put
these things in a program and find out
that they're faked. There's no way that
a square gets put around the Earth if
you're taking a photograph of Earth from
the moon. Me, as a graphic designer, I
know all about this. I use Photoshop
constantly. If you have the magic wand
tool and you make sure that the
tolerance level is all the way down,
it's only going to select that exact
color. If it's any different shade, it's
going to show you and reveal it. This is
another proof that whenever went to the
moon that these pictures are fake. This
is straight off of NASA's website. It
says from a million miles away, NASA's
camera shows moon crossing face of
Earth. Now, look at this. This is the
dark side of the moon that we're seeing.
This is from I guess a satellite that's
higher than the moon and it actually
caught footage of the moon going across
the earth. What I want you to notice is
the clouds. They are not moving
one inch. The clouds do not move at all
in this video of the rotation of the
Earth. You know how fast clouds move?
The website says that these images were
taken [music] between 3:50 p.m. and 8:45
p.m. So 5 hours of footage and not a
single cloud has moved. Also notice the
sun is behind the camera which is
illuminating the moon and yet the moon
is not casting a shadow on Earth at all.
This should be a solar eclipse that's
casting the moon's shadow on Earth, but
there's no shadow. When the moon comes
between Earth and the [music] Sun, it
casts a shadow on Earth.
>> Come on, man. This is straight from
NASA. Be honest with yourself. This is
not real. I'm I'm looking at different
things that make me know this isn't
real. There's some weird like lighting
on the edge of Earth here. This is a
perfect circle. Neil Degrass Tyson says
that Earth is pear-shaped.
>> So, it's not actually a sphere. It's an
[music] it's oblate. And officially,
it's an oblate spheroid. That's what we
call it. It's slightly wider below the
equator than above the
>> little chubbier.
>> Little chubbier. Yeah, chubby is a good
way. It's like pear-shaped. Pear-shaped.
Pear-shaped. Pear-shaped. Pear-shaped.
>> Come on, man. Like, this is not adding
up. There's no consistency with space,
the Globe, NASA, these physicists. This
is not a pear-shaped Earth. This is a
exact, perfectly round photoshopped
circular Earth. [music] And the clouds
don't change formation at all. We're
going to listen to Don Pettis say that
he'd go to the moon in a nancond except
they destroyed that technology.
>> I'd go to the moon in a nancond.
The problem is we don't have the
technology to do that anymore. We used
to, but we uh destroyed that [music]
technology and it's a painful process to
build it back again. It's a painful
process, dude. We have computers in our
pocket. We we are all walking around
with computers in our pocket that can
stream video to thousands of people.
Back then in 1969 there may have been an
Atari. Like the computer level back then
compared to now and you're saying that
if you just look at the Moonlander, that
thing looks like it was made by
kindergarteners. Literally, it looked
like a science project put together with
shower curtain rods and and gold foil
and a shed. There's like a storage shed
on top and it seemed like there was like
three different versions of how they
went to space. They got in a rocket.
That thing flies up. It turns into the
lunar module, the thing with legs and
feet that don't have any dust on them
when they land. And then somehow when
they got in there, that thing was able
to take off and go back to Earth and
land as some kind of capsule from a
parachute. Dude, there's nothing about
this that I'm buying. And and here's
these guys saying that they can't go
they can't go higher than lower earth
orbit.
>> Right now we only can fly in Earth
orbit. That's the farthest that we can
go. And this new system that we're
building is going to allow us to go
beyond and hopefully take humans into
the solar system to explore. So the
moon, Mars, asteroids, there's a lot of
destinations that we could go to. And
we're building these building block
components in order to allow us to do
that eventually. So he just said we can
only go to lower earth orbit, but maybe
one day we could go to places like the
moon and Mars.
You mean like we did in 1969? This is
crazy. And then here's where he's saying
we need we need to build shielding on
Orion, which is this other space capsule
thing. There's not enough shielding to
get through the Van Allen radiation
belts. But they had they would have had
to have gone through the Van Allen
radiation belts to go to the moon in
1969. And now we're talking about we
need to build shielding that can get
humans and computers on board computers
through that radiation. Check this out.
>> My name is Kelly Smith and I work on
navigation and guidance for Orion. Orion
is NASA's next generation spacecraft.
[music]
Built with versatility in mind, it can
take astronauts deeper into space than
we've ever gone before, to an asteroid
[music] or even onto Mars. For these
missions, Orion has to be one tough
spacecraft, withstanding high speeds,
searing temperatures, and extreme
radiation.
Before we can send astronauts into space
on Orion, we have to test all of its
systems. And there's only one way to
know if we got it right. Fly it in
space.
As we get further away from Earth, we'll
pass through the Van Allen belts, an
area of dangerous radiation.
Radiation like this could harm the
guidance systems, [music] onboard
computers, or other electronics on
Orion. Naturally, we have to pass
through this danger zone twice. Once up
[music] and once back. We must solve
these challenges before we send people
through this region of space. For this
flight, it's time to head home. He's
literally telling you we can't go
through the Van Allen radiation belts.
Whether you believe in Van Allen
radiation belts or not. I don't anymore.
I used to when I first heard about this
stuff, but now I believe that there's a
firmament. Either way, you can't go to
space. And so, I think the Van Allen
radiation belts is kind of the deception
to explain why we can't go to space or
why we can't go to the moon. But he's
literally saying like this was years
after we went to the moon and he's
[music] saying we are still working on
shielding to be able to get through that
those radiation belts not just for
humans but for even onboard computers.
So answer me this. How do we have a a
little remote control car on Mars right
now? That's a onboard computer. And how
are we controlling it from Earth? I
can't even get a signal on my phone when
I go into the mountains. or on an
airplane, but we can control a remote
control car from Earth. Come on, guys.
We've been [music] duped. Here's a a
question asked to one of the astronauts
by Bart Sabre, the guy we just had on.
Listen to how their stories never line
up.
>> Any ill effects from the Van Allen
radiation belt?
>> No. Now, I'm not sure we went far enough
out to to encounter the Van Allen
radiation belt. Maybe we did. Every
space mission in history with humans on
board, from both the United States and
Soviet Union, from the first in 1961 to
the present, has been well below this
deadly radiation field. Mercury, Gemini,
Soyos, Skylab, the space shuttle, all
maintained altitudes well below 1,000 m.
All except Apollo.
I don't know the distance to the Van
Allen radiation belt and [music] if we
did it wasn't a problem.
>> The belts are 1,000 miles to 25,000 mi
above the Earth.
>> We then we went right out through them.
>> No effects on yourselves.
>> Didn't even know it. I don't think
anybody Well, maybe somebody said you
went through the radiation bell, but we
didn't feel it inside. You went to the
moon and you don't you had to go through
months of training and going through all
these different things and you don't
even know where the vanel and radiation
belts are. Like you weren't primed for
that and prepped like hey now when you
get this far up you might feel a little
uncomfortable because there's severe
bands of radiation that you're going to
be going through. And he's like no we we
must have went right through it. I I
didn't even know about it. Two
astronauts were asked, "Is the the
engine is it loud?" This is what they
said. Two conflicting stories.
>> Is the engine loud as you're descending?
>> Well, the engine is very loud. It's very
difficult to tell the difference between
feeling sound and hearing sound, but
yes, it's loud.
>> When you were in it, you couldn't hear
it in the vacuum of space.
>> If you ask two people, "Hey, you both
were at that party last night. Was the
music loud?" And one person was like,
"Oh, yeah, it was very loud." And the
other person was like, "I don't know. I
couldn't hear it." You would be like,
"What? What's going on? Were you guys
really both at that party or not?"
I mean, this is this is damning
evidence. These are liars. These people
are lying. Now, when Buzz Aldrin was
asked, "Why haven't we been to the moon
in such a long time?" he has a very
interesting answer. Check this out.
>> Why has nobody been to the moon in such
a long time?
That's not
an 8-year-old's question. [laughter]
That's my question. I want to know, but
I think I know
cuz we didn't go there. And
and that's the way it happened. And and
if it didn't happen, it's nice to know
why it didn't happen. So,
>> okay. Uh, that's just the craziest
answer ever. There's no Look, people can
say context, whatever. Go look it up.
It's like a 17minute long video. This
girl's dad, I'm sure, um, asked her to
ask him these questions. And that's why
he gives like a nervous laugh when he
goes, "Oh, that's not an 8-year-old
question." The dad's like, but then he's
saying, "That's my question. [music] Go
watch it." There's no context that will
make what he said make make sense. If he
literally went to the moon, no context
can explain what he just said.
>> Why has nobody been to the moon in such
a long time?
>> Cuz we didn't. Cuz we didn't. Cuz we
didn't go there. And
And that's the way it happened. And And
if it didn't happen, it's nice to know
why it didn't happen. So
>> it would be nice to know why it didn't
happen. I want to know. Now, check this
out. This is crazy. So, George Bush is
being pushed through the space center
and there's footage, live, quote unquote
live footage from the ISS going on in
the background. What do you see that's
interesting in the background? I see a a
blue screen with a grid on it. That same
guy is right here showing you how you
can play with a bubble of water in
space. Now, why is the background blue
with a grid on it and he's got a green
ball? This is special effects happening
right caught right there on television
while they're pushing George Bush. This
blue grid is how they do live
compositing, live keying because the
camera and the com and the software can
pick up on that grid and even if the
camera moves, the background moves with
it so that you look like you're in the
environment. And this is live keying.
This is exactly what they're doing. The
ISS has been there's been so many things
that have shown that the ISS is faking
it. Whether it's harness wires or green
screen glitches or bubbles in space or
hairsprayed hair instead of it flowing
around. And we're going to look at some
of that stuff. I'm going to show you
these clips that I put together. And uh
I want you to just be honest with
yourself while you're watching these
clips. Um, you see this guy doing a back
flip and people are grabbing wires
behind him, grabbing his wire on his
leg. This guy, he actually falls halfway
[music] through his flip. Um, this guy,
he he tries to bend down and can only go
so far. This guy can't even do a back
flip and zero G. And this lady grabs a
wire. She stands up. Now, I'm going to
show you all these. [music] Compare them
side by side. Look, this guy is
definitely struggling with a harness
wire on the left. This guy on the
right's grabbing a cord that you can see
attached [snorts] to his pants. And the
guy in the background is swatting at a a
wire he's trying to grab.
Here, the guy on the left falls halfway
through his flip. And on the right, this
guy is lunging to do a back flip. And if
this was zero G, he would just continue
[music] to go on. But he doesn't. Um,
here on the left we see this lady grab a
wire as she stands up or she's just
grabbing nothing [music] maybe. I don't
know. On the right, this guy bends down
but is stopped by resistance and you see
his shirt lift up in the back.
So, I mean, you just have to be honest
with yourself. Is this zerog? Is this
really the ISS going on? Uh, these are
scenes from the movie called Life.
[music] It's about the ISS and you can
see how they're floating around with
harnesses. I think this is how they're
doing it. [snorts]
Uh, this lady's hair is just stiff as a
board standing straight up and that's
her proof that they're on the ISS.
This lady's hair is bouncing right back
in place as she bends down. I've
reversed it back and forth so [music]
you can see how she moves her head
forward and instead of her hair freely
flowing forward, bounces back in place.
Same with this Medusa chick [music]
here. [snorts] Um, she's definitely in a
zero G plane because she's floating
around, but her hair is hairsprayed
stiff. Now, if you were just going to
keep your hair out of your way, I would
pull it back in a ponytail,
but uh, she's got a stiff. Now, this is
what your hair would do in zero G.
Freely move. Not stiff as a board like
we see on the right here. This is
hairspray. This looks exactly like what
we see on the ISS.
Now, sometimes we do see hair moving
freely on the ISS when it's a uh an
edited
shot, you know, just little clips. But
if there's any long periods of shots or
live, they definitely do the hairspray
so [music] you can't tell when the plane
levels out. But look at this hair freely
flowing on the ISS. So, both of these
are from the ISS, but their hair is
doing [music] completely different
things. So,
uh you come up with your own conclusion
here.
But this is how I expect people to fly
around on the ISS just corkcrewing and
going all crazy, but they always just do
this back flip or this front flip, this
stiff flip, and then gravity hits. Boom.
Whoop.
There's that gravity. There's no
consistency. I don't know. I don't
understand why people will choose to
believe this lie when they can see it
right there in sideby-side comparisons
that [music] there's zero consistency.
This is a lie. They are caught
red-handed. There's evidence proof,
video proof that they're lying. This
technology is not difficult. People act
like there's no way you can fake this
stuff. And it's very simple. If you've
ever watched a movie even as far back as
2001 [music] of space odyssey that was a
year before the moon landing happened
and they were floating around in space.
Imagine what we can do now with the
technology we have now. This is one of
the first footages of a spacew walk
[music] where he comes out of the
spaceship. Watch that head turn.
Watch it turn and look at the camera as
he waves. I'm going to show you again.
He turns his head and waves. [music]
How can an astronaut turn his head? Does
an astronaut's helmet turn? No. An
astronaut's helmet does not turn. AI is
scouring the internet and getting the
best answer for your question. Does an
astronaut's helmet turn? No. But we just
saw it happen. This is where NASA trains
[music]
astronauts before they can go to space.
I'm here with Terry Dunn. You're the
training operations manager. And Terry,
we're in front of a space suit,
>> right? This is the extra vehicular
mobility unit or EMU as we call it. And
it's the space suit that astronauts wear
for spacew walks, either the space
shuttle back in those days or the space
station now.
>> And so this is in use. This is in the
design that's been used for decades,
>> right? It's essentially unchanged for
the past 40 years.
>> He said it was used for spacew walks. He
said it was unchanged for decades.
Listen to what he says. design that's
been used for decades,
>> right? It's essentially unchanged for
the past 40 years.
>> This right here, this astronaut space
suit is the same model that has been
used for decades. Nothing's changed.
Listen,
>> and this is a a very rigid suit. Like
there's not a lot of mobility in here,
>> right? The upper part that they call it
the hard upper torso for a reason. It's
um really a hard shell. And despite the
obvious comfort level of that, there's a
reason for it. And you've got to have
all these different things. The life
support system, the controls for the
suit, your tools, all have to be rigidly
mounted. So, you need that hard shell to
be able to do that.
>> You need that hard shell, that rigidness
at the top. Okay, we we're getting a
little bit closer, but here is the nail
in the coffin.
>> And with the helmet on, the helmet
doesn't turn when the astronaut's head
turns.
>> That's right. Your field of view is very
limited. [music]
>> The helmet doesn't turn when the
astronaut's head turns.
>> That's right. Your field of view is very
limited. So is your situational
awareness. And so you can basically look
almost all the way to your right and
left and then you need to be able to
look down as well.
>> Correct. So if you need to see beyond
those views, you're turning your whole
torso like you're in traction.
>> You're turning your whole torso. He's
saying the helmet doesn't move. And this
is newer. This is like a newer model. He
could have said, "Yeah, back in the day,
you know, we didn't have the technology
to make your head move, but now we do."
No, he's saying this model, the helmet
doesn't move and it's [music] the same
unchanged model that we've used for
decades on spacew walks. We're building
the whole evidence. The whole evidence
is what we saw was footage of a spacew
walk. We saw a helmet turn. It looked
like claymation changed astronaut
[music] suit and it doesn't turn. The
helmet does not turn. You have to turn
your whole body. Come on. Are we going
to lie to ourselves? Are we going to
continue to believe this fairy tale just
because what we think it's fun [music]
or we don't want to believe that we've
been lied to? Why are we still believing
this? So, how much did the original moon
buggy cost? I just think this is
interesting. The original moon buggy,
also known as the lunar roving vehicle,
had an initial contract cost of $19
million. $19 million for that thing. But
due to cost overruns, the final price
reached $38 million.
$38 million. You want to see what that
looks like?
That's $38 million, guys. That seriously
looks like two lawn chairs on a on a
door with wheels attached to it. How can
that cost $38 million?
$38 million, guys. And that was back in
1969.
Come on, dude. 1969. $38 million for a
doom buggy. And not even a really nice
one. This is insane, guys. So, the
astronauts got back inside the the moon
lander and they're going back home to
Earth.
Who is recording this?
They left the cameraman. They left a
cameraman on the moon just for this
shot. And it's not just a It's not like,
okay, they left a camera. Big deal. We
left a cam. Cameras are very expensive.
It had the footage in it. How do we get
How do we even get this footage? How are
they live streaming in 1969?
Dude, I'm starting to like just Dude,
there's nothing about this that makes
sense.
How was astronauts
live streaming in 1969 when every phone
had a cord attached to the wall? There
was nothing wireless. Oh my goodness,
dude. How did How did anybody believe
this? Look at this.
The camera pans up. It's not just a
camera left on a tripod. [music]
And like I was saying, the footage would
have had the the camera would have had
the footage in it.
Unless they're somehow live streaming,
and I guess they did. I guess somehow
they at least had the public fooled that
you could live stream from the moon in
1969 with VHS [music]
camcorders.
And they left someone on the moon to
record the the flight back home. Oh my
goodness, guys. Oh, we're so gullible
sometimes. I hope this was eye opening
for you guys. Like if you were never a
skeptic, if you never thought about
this, maybe the wheels are turning. If
you had heard about it but thought it
was nonsense, of course we went to the
moon. I pray that something shown here
was like, h maybe I need to look into
this more. But I just thank you guys for
being here. I love talking about these
topics. [music] The truth will set you
free. That's what we're here for. The
candid truth. We want to talk about the
truth and we want to get candid with it.
I hope you guys enjoy this. If you did,
please give it a thumbs up. It really
helps get this video out into the
algorithm so more people can see it. If
you've [music] never subscribed to this
channel, please take a moment and hit
that little subscribe button. Press the
little bell icon so you won't [music]
miss another episode like this. And if
you would like to donate to this
ministry, we have ways of doing that
through Cash [music] App, Vinmo, Zel, if
you go to candidtruth.org, you can click
the donate button and donate through
PayPal. And it's because of you guys
that we can even continue to do this
ministry. [music] And because of that,
we'll see you next time. I love you
guys. God bless.